or congratulations on this movie guys
it's really really great now with this
movie this is essentially these three
characters through the course of the
film so how did you as a director and as
actor how do you guys create that
dynamic before you start shooting to
make sure the chemistry is all there
between the three of you we we our
schedules were crazy we got all our
actors right off of other movies you
know with and so with the exception of
Jack who came early to do boxing
training
Charlie had come straight from Australia
Jess had come from England Australia
oh you were Australia too and we I mean
we just casting is is you know the whole
name of the game there wasn't that you
know when people say we had two months
where the actors went to boot camp and
Fall River and you know we didn't have
that it also wasn't the money to pay me
today there's no money in the world and
so it was just you know for us it was
just casting the right actors and and
having faith that that would be enough
and and I think it was I just clicked
for you guys like first day pretty much
I mean it's always sort of inexplicable
what creates good chemistry and how it
works and unless you do what you just
talked about which is you know go
through some punishing cycles of
chemistry reeds and all of that which
I've done that before actually and then
we got onto set and me and the girl had
absolutely no chemistry so that doesn't
always work but we I think we just
honestly got lucky and probably max
intuitive's you know he put together you
know he spent time with each of us
individually and probably was feeling it
out but you know there's always more
than anything is an element of luck and
professionalism because sometimes even
if there isn't innate chemistry you can
construct it by just sheer determination
or blood sweat and tears so fortunately
that wasn't required on this I mean I'd
say with both your characters there's so
much life lived before we meet so how do
you gotta just kind of come up with what
the backstory is for your characters I
mean that's the part of being an actress
that I really enjoy and that's one of
the things I enjoy the most even if
you're not working with a direct
that necessarily wants to know about it
I feel like you would all I don't know
like it's just like you would talk about
it some people don't want to know some
people are just like I don't I'm not
bothered like we're just here to do
what's in the script and but I think
it's really fun whether or not somebody
wants you to do it I would always do it
anyway and I don't know like I'm just
kind of like I'm really weird though
like I will delete rly like say
literally like on the soup I will like
yeah yeah but I'll like just sit
somewhere and listen to music and like
think about what character and they're
like but what just before I go film
something every single time I make a
decision for myself like I'll think
about what the characters would decide
to do even if it's like wall I'm gonna
eat for my lunch but this is just all
like just part of like being me like I
don't do it on purpose
and then yeah I did make a Sookie I made
like the suitcase that she carries
around it but you designed it like your
high school self would have done I
actually tried really hard everybody was
like wow this is amazing so authentic
it's so gross and I'm like yeah I wanted
it to be like that because especially
like even there's lines in the movie
Charlie with your character that you
know stuff is referred to that we don't
see but yeah you know these people
already you've had this previous life
yes so how do you create that for
yourself that the audience isn't
necessarily gonna learn on that but it's
all into that but yeah I mean honestly
that I think a lot of that is satisfied
by the writing you know that you know
those suggestions and then so a lot of
that work in that that that passed like
the foundation of these characters has
been really sort of intricately worked
through by the writing team and so you
know what was really most important for
me was just understanding exactly what
the dynamic was between these two
brothers and how they'd been living you
know in really what was the just the
essential thing was just to convey that
we had spent every second of our lives
together you know and the details of
that were less important than the impact
of it and so you know I did you know we
we didn't have the luxury of a lot of
time to spend together Jack and I but
soon as we were in the same place we
spent pretty much every minute together
and you know we lived very close to each
other in this very rural area and you
know I'd make him dinner and oh that's
good
come on focus orgies cigarettes it like
literally and wake me up and I would
just say he's your little brother and
you love him just going kickin we had
dinner the three of us and we know you
weren't invited
no everyone had their one dish that they
were doing and Jack was working on the
green beans bill in the cold on the corn
in the corn went in the oven and we're
all hanging out I was curious about it
and we heard an explosion that made me
think somehow we max and I like what
like massive like a violent glass
explosion in judges window guess I was
nothing proof continue to eat the corn
you wanted everyone glass like I was at
boys corns wonderful wonderful Jimmy uh
he does much good okay yeah this movies
had like a pretty long life back so do
you like she's getting into schools
hello it's been years right the first
time I was in Toronto with my first
movie I think was eight years ago maybe
I don't know the exact date but I had
that script of version like a very bad
version and that script with me like in
Toronto that I was working on and you
know I would I'd made other movies and
stuff in between and they this was
always the thing I wanted to make most
because I just it channeled all the
stuff that I love about movies that made
me want to make movies to begin with so
yeah it's been around for a long time
and then Charlie you know with Charlie
was the first actor to come aboard and
through a series of coincidences he came
on board and and within that was in the
spring and within months we were
shooting which was incredible yeah this
is the third feature is my third movie
but you still ask your dad for advice
did you get it if I said
you want to kind of keep though at that
world separate eye he's a great dad and
I love him very much and he's got really
good advice for for everything yeah yeah
Jessica what's it like working with this
guy it's really great yeah he's a really
good director it was a really it was a
challenge I think the movie was
challenging because we were filming in
an area that like you don't film in and
it was a challenging movie we moved
around a lot and the subject matter that
we were making and the types of people
that you're representing like the scenes
when I was easy or difficult scenes to
do we did a lot of night shoes hmm just
things like this was a challenging shoe
it was enjoyable but it's challenging
and you know it helps when you're
working with the director that is never
in any way like you were never like
negative about anything like you were
just really happy and grateful to be
made know like you still have that thing
that I don't know like usually like
newer directors have it but I think good
directors always retain it where the
fact that you are making your movie the
novelty of it like never wears off so
you're just grateful and happy to make
in your movie every day sometimes like
directors lose that like as they go on
but only the good ones keep it like they
don't care but you could be filming in
like a snowstorm or you could just be
filming with like actors are completely
terrible but they're still gonna love
making the movie and everybody is happy
to be there working for a director like
that yeah it's a miracle we got to make
this movie you know movies like this one
are getting more and more squeezed out
one turn off your phone come on who is
it I wish it was something cool it was
Verizon Wireless saying my roaming dates
about to run out she really buy a plan
for that I should live with someone cool
that's a final thing I totally feel like
with your career you're always rumored
to be considered for roles like it's not
a worth that iknow people are talking at
Wolverine I've heard that one that wants
to play Wolverine because now the Hugh
Jackman's are tired
and then the other one is green arrow
that people keep on talking about yeah I
had - did you see the green arrow
did you see the fan art that went like
viral last week like someone made
someone made like fan art of you as the
green arrow like someone made that I
mean that could be anyway people always
wanted you to play like yeah there's
rules like what's that is that weird
well you know it's it's just sort of you
know it's it's neither here nor there
because until you actually get a call
it's all just the you know it's it's
it's not really generated from the
inside you know so it's it's nice
flattering it's really flattering yeah
but you know in actually on the green
arrow that there was a little smoke
behind that fire or fire behind that
smell Stephen Amell was just finishing
there also now there's a chance right
was that a TV show yeah arrows just
finishing the seasons right yeah the
cinematic world and it's a he's part of
the DC you know yeah yeah so I mean send
me that ya know I mean it's really
really flattering I mean you know if any
of the ones that I sort of took notice
of and I think it was only mentioned a
couple times but bond would be the one
that oh really yeah you should be
talking about me for that because I
think we pretty dope would give me a
good chance I don't think I don't think
I actually do you say boys before is it
he says Jackson bond James Bond males it
awesome well thank you guys
congratulations thank you great thank
you I was lost
you